In flow monitoring, a monitor which might actually be running on the router
itself, records statistics per-flow. A flow
consists of packets that share a common
source and destination IP address, source
and destination port, protocol type, TOS byte
and interface, on which the packets arrive.
A flow monitor can then record statistics
for a flow, that's defined by the group
of packets that share these features. The flow
records may also contain additional information, such as
the next hop IP address, and other information related
to routing. Such as the source and destination
AS on which those packets appear to be coming
from and going to, based on the routing
tables, as well as the prefix that those packets
matched in the routing table. Flow monitoring is
much less overhead than packet monitoring, but it's
also much more coarse than packet monitoring because
the monitor does not see individual packets or payloads.
Therefore, it's impossible to get certain information from
flow monitoring. Such as packet timing information. In
addition to grouping packets into flows based on
the fact that they share common elements in their
headers, typically packets are grouped into flows if they occur close
together in time. So for example, if packets that share
common sets of header fields do not appear for a particular
time interval, such as 15 or 30 seconds,
the router simply declares the flow to be
over, and sends a flow record to the
monitor based on the group of packets that it's
seen up to that point. Sometimes, to reduce monitoring
overhead, flow level monitoring may also be accompanied with
samples. Sampling builds flow statistics based only on samples
of the packets. So, for examples, flows may be created based on
one out of every ten or 100 packets. Or a packet
might be sampled with a particular probability
and flow statistics might only be tabulated based
on the packets that end up being sampled randomly from the total set of packets.